jede woche wo in den nachstunden
publiziert wird
ich sage das gerade noch erleben und wir
haben noch einen moment länger von
dieser yvonne catterfeld die bemüht ist
ihr autos image abzustreifen und aus
ernsthafte musikerin wahrgenommen zu
werden das ist nicht ganz einfach denn
sie war das schätzchen der nation bei
gute zeiten schlechte zeiten
sie hat aber bevor sie dort angefangen
hat musik studiert populäre musik und
tanz in leipzig und was wollte man
kollegen in orient verifizieren er hat
sich von yvonne catterfeld etwas
vorsingen lassen
er konnte yvonne catterfeld flankiert
von gitarrist und meine rente alt ganz
top da
angereist ist die um in frankfurt ihre
neuen songs vorzustellen
[Musik]
immer mehr pflicht als pflichttermine
inzwischen kann ich mir ein privileg
dass ich so lange dabei wird dann doch
auch sagen was ich gerne machen möchte
sie geht dem weg die so viele gehen
wollen richtig erfolgreich wurde sie als
blonder julia blumen in der soap gzsz
und mit dieter bohlen song für dich
dominierte sie monatelang die charts
[Musik]
ein
das seichte liebchen haftet an der
ausgebildete musikerin und damit das
image des harmlos mädchens yvonne
catterfeld wird ständig unterschätzt
wenn man aber man spürt die
erwartungshaltung so niedrig ist dass
man einfach weiß okay ich kann
eigentlich nicht verlieren kann
eigentlich nur gewinnen und aber es
irgendwann frustrierend weil für mich
ist erfolg oder für mich steht für mich
fühlen sich dinge erst gut an wenn ich
mein potenzial ausschöpfen kann
potenzial ausschöpfen bedeutet für die
sängerin
sie gründet nach 16 jahren im showbiz
ihre eigene plattenfirma bringt ihr
album guten morgen freiheit selbst raus
und sie allein bestimmt was sie singt
wie sie auftritt worüber sie spricht ich
habe einfach immer mehr gespürt wie ich
mich doch anderer meinung mancher irre
geführt haben und zu viele meinung auch
auf mich eingeprasselt sind das
popsternchen von einst ist passé
einzig die texte ihrer lieder erinnern
stark an die alten bodenzeiten ihre
stimme hat an reife gewonnen und ihre
klaren vorstellungen klinik
[Musik]
ok
mit fachwissen überzeugt sie auch als
juror in einer castingshow der rote wie
ein ritterschlag in der branche ist dass
die geglückte emanzipation im
entertainment also ich würde es eher
mich emanzipation sondern irgendwie
zions verfolgung oder sowas oder
selbstvertrauen den sprung zur
unternehmerin hat yvonne catterfeld
definitiv geschah allerdings mit dem
alten erfolgsrezept eingängiger text
trifft auf eingängige melodie aber
nichts denn jetzt profitiert ihr einzig
sie selbst na dann
[Musik]